well in our special report tonight
nearly 600 nevadans are on the oregon
waiting list but our state only has one
transplant institute for the entire
state and we only do one organ let's
take a look now other states let's say
like colorado for instance has four
transplant centers if we look at arizona
and washington state they each have five
and out here in missouri eight
transplant centers so if you live here
and you need a life-saving lung heart or
liver you're not going to get it here
but a group is trying to change that so
here's the long-term plan for
transplants in nevada
i was struggling to get a kidney here so
they recommended going out of state
kirsten nozzardo is one of thousands of
nevadans forced to leave the state for
an organ transplant we needed to be down
there for six weeks minimum if things
went well once the couple got the call
they dropped everything to get to the
mayo clinic in phoenix at the height of
the pandemic i had to give her kiss
goodbye and wave her through the door i
couldn't even go in umc is the only
transplant center in our state and it
only performs kidney transplants last
year it did 138 a heart transplant a
lung transplant a
liver pancreas transplant nevadans are
having to leave and relocate outside of
our state stephen peralta is the
foundation president for the nevada
donor network right now there are nearly
600 nevadans on the waiting list and
many of them will have to relocate to
save their lives your son has
hypertrophic cardiomyopathy that's
exactly what oscar gamboa and his mother
did they spent six months in los angeles
getting his heart transplant
that time away creates a huge financial
and emotional burden being able to take
her and put her on her own couch or her
own bed to
fully just recuperate would have been so
much easier elevating and expanding umc
to a fully accredited institute will
take time and money about 35 million
dollars the donor network is about a
third of the way there to recruit the
necessary talent the physicians and the
transplant teams to live and work here
and the second piece of that of our
philanthropic campaign
is to fund the first 12
plus new transplants that are needed
those new transplants will be livers
hopefully later this year it needs to
pay for and successfully carry out at
least a dozen procedures which is why
it's raising so much money we've got to
get accredited first we've got to get
licensed once we're able to do that just
like any other hospital procedure we can
now get reimbursed it'll take years to
eventually offer all organ transplants
for those waiting the procedure will
likely mean leaving your home living
your job and even your family in order
to stay alive enjoy
what you can enjoy yeah enjoy enjoy life
every minute of it
and by the way southern nevadans are
very generous when it comes to becoming
an organ donor about 54 of our state are
registered that's actually higher than
the national average but we need more
diversity more latinos more asians more
african americans in order to turn organ
donation into that gift of life